I'm King Nu. Thank you very much.
[Music] I'd like to start
by introducing myself. Please
tell me about the history of Kae Band and the origin of the band name.
I'm Kazu Arai, the bassist of Kae. I
'm Tsuneta.  I'm Yu Seki on the drums, and I'm Cal Iguchi on the keyboard.First of
all, I'd like to say that the two of us
did it together, but strictly speaking, it started before that, but
Makoto and the four of us
started it.  Later on, the
two people on the left joined the band, and
I was connected to U on the drums, and
Saru and Daigo
are also childhood friends of the band, so it seems like that's what I'm talking about.  To
give you a rough idea of ​​how it happened, it's something like that.We
originally had a different band name, but
when we debuted, we decided to change the name a little bit, so we decided to call it
Ma King Noo.So, we
came up with the idea for an animal called Ema Noo.  However, the wildebeest is a
symbol of disrespectful animals,
and the
name King Gnu
comes from the feeling that the wildebeest can lead the way.Igor Stravinsky was one of the artists who influenced us when we formed the band.  Even
Jimmy
Hendrix has been mentioned many times
, but since then the number of artists who have influenced me
has increased.I see him regularly, and that's why he's such a
hot person.There's a
boom when he's hot.
There are some small differences between each of them, but it seems a bit distorted.That's right,
Chad in that Rechiri drama.I feel like there was a
time when the feeling of Un was slightly shifted.It
was a big Un Satoru.  Annoe
Lately, I've been listening to some R&B,
right? Lately, I've been listening to Daniel,
Daniel Siza, Daniel Siza,
yeah, I've been listening to it, I've been listening to it, and I've been trying to
listen to it. Yeah, yeah, recently, I've been
kind of breaking away from JP.  There's
something that seems like a bit of a secret theme, so yeah, it's a lot more pop than it was a while ago, and when I
say pop, I'm conscious of it from somewhere.Let's
go to the ceremony.  I wonder if that's true.The
songs on this album are the
songs on this album, especially from this year.That's right.Yeah, I feel
like I get it.That's true.The
physique of recent recordings, etc.
Your music is sometimes
referred to as Tokyo music.I wonder
how King Nu's music has evolved as you continue to be active.Nandone,
how has
this
evolution been with this album?  I can definitely feel the change in the sound image,
but I ca
n't really put into words what it is.I've only just
finished the album, so I can't put it into words.
I don't think so, but I do feel that way,
or rather, I feel a positive response.Yes,
Next Specials is a song that is
really perfect for the opening of the anime Jujutsu Line Shibuya Chihen.Even
before I made the song, I was a
fan of Jujutsu Line anime and manga.  I guess that's what it was, but I
like the Shibuya Incident quite a lot.I guess I'm
really happy to be in charge of it.The
content is a bit difficult, I guess.The
worldview and so on.
I'm doing an anime this time, so it's like I
read it all over again from the beginning. Yeah, it's
interesting. I'm kind of
curious about the sequel. Yeah, I'm
curious about the sequel, right? I'm really
curious. I'm curious about the sequel. Now.  No. 1 I'm
curious about the continuation.It's hot right now, so it's the hottest.Yes, that's right.No,
Tsuneda-san and Iguchi-san
's vocals play a
beautiful melody in the form of a call-a-response in the Specials.This
in the music video.
The sequence seems to depict a hero vs. villain,
and I think the
creativity was inspired by the image of the Cursed Line, which may or
may not be the case overall, but maybe not
at all.  I
don't think
so.
Well, both of them might be villains.
This one and this one, even in
the end. That's right. There
is a sense of justice in everything and everything, and it seems that it depends on the beauty of that one.  The
Shibuya Hen has a similar structure. I'm
drowning. I do
n't have
any reinforcements now. Let's jump in and help. Kakuichi Kakudai-sama.
Ranking Jujutsu Line Zero Banana Fish
has also provided music for anime, but the
songwriting for anime is normal.
How is it different from composing songs for albums
?The style I create is more
suited to the real world, so
it's easier to create songs for anime.  Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I
feel like it's a lot of freedom.  Yes, yes, it's
quite difficult. Yes, that's right.
Teenager Forever's
music video not only introduces the members,
but also gives us a glimpse into everyone's personal lives.
It's true. It was completed with the filming of the music video. You
can't see it in the version.  There
were special moments for everyone,
like Satoru, and all sorts of things.Ah, the
Philippines, basically.Whatever we did, it was
fun.Yo, what's the
Philippines?Eh, it
wasn't a record call or anything.  The
fact that everything is shown
doesn't mean it's like that, but I'm
showing you the softest parts of it all, so that's the
only thing I can show in the music video, and there
are some parts that I couldn't show in the music video.It's so beautiful, walking on the beach.  They were
holding hands and holding hands for a bit.I couldn't see it in reverse.Oh, I
see.You guys
won the 2019 MTV Video MUSIC JAPAN's Video Ozire award in broad daylight.This
video has a different art compared to Kingnu's other
music videos.  It
looks like the direction has been adopted.What do you think is the reason why the creative of this video
won the award that year?Oh, yes, yes, I did that with all my might.That's right, I was
thinking about doing that tomorrow.Yes, that's right,
as the bottom.  I
think it's a public recording, and I think it's
like a public performance, and I think it's kind of cheap to include a PA person
and the story, but I
think I want to do it in the most pure and clean way possible.
I guess it's a good thing that it doesn't have any strange meaning,
but
as a result, we do have career goals and
milestones that we've set towards achieving them.  I
think being transparent means making the dome tour a success, but yeah, of course, that
's what I'm focusing on right now,
so I'm trying
not to get too excited about anything else like that, and it's my first album release in four years.
Congratulations on The Greatest Record
[Music] I
feel like I'm making music, so I
feel like I'm
getting back to that point of view.It's amazing how life feels when the spotlight isn't on you.  I want to cherish it, so I'm
doing it. [Music] Yes, from here on, it's a fire question. Yes, my favorite anime is
Anime Anime. Yes, everyone will answer. Yes,
then please go ahead. Is this the mobile unit?
Taka is the mobile unit.  My body is Yellow Submarine
Hey, it's nostalgic.Studio
Ghibli.Well, that's right.It's taller than I expected.I
recently watched Jigokuraku, which was an interesting anime.Ah, it was
interesting.Yes, it was interesting.What
kind of anime did you watch when you were a child?
Yes, it's the starting player Gundam, right? It's
Gundam. Gundam. What seed? Early.
Early. Yeah, no, it's not Pokemon. I saw it, but it's
Pokemon. I'm sure it's
Pokemon. It's not Ghibli. But I'll say it anyway. And it's Conan.  No Conan or I
am Inuyashi. Ah, that's a nostalgic obi. Ungo. It's so
nostalgic around there. Conan Inuya. Kona. Oh yeah, that's right. It's Inuya. I
want Mr. Inoue to write about artists and bands he would like to collaborate with.  There are things like ``
One Piece,'' and ``
Oda
Ichiro,'' who is an artist, and ``Taichiro,'' and there are some things that I would like to see made into characters,
but please tell me the three stations you've been listening to lately.  I'm
listening to Fitness Club.
Oh, I'm
listening to Sal, Ade Spear, and Stevens.
Lately, I've been
listening to a lot of folk music. I haven't been listening to Boynewell lately,
but I haven't been listening to much Sampha
albums and new albums lately.  There's an artist called Jeans and Zamarias,
and I've been
listening to their songs. It's hard to narrow down the list to just three songs. I mostly
listen to them on albums, so
yeah, yeah, yeah, what did I want to be when I grew up?  It
's famous back in the day, no, it was a nursery school, or
something like that.Back then, I was a photographer.Photographer,
cool, cool, cool, cool,
cool, cameraman, yeah, well, hey, Thomas, oh, I
liked Thomas, I liked
Thomas, I wanted to be Thomas, I
wanted to be Thomas.  That's why I wanted to be that
special Thomas with that look Poss, that
face, lots of that It looks
like I'll be able to collaborate with Thomas Well, it must be a dream Well, maybe it turned out
unexpectedly Well, I might
have been a hero Oh
yeah, the acrophysis was also on point  Natoko:
Yeah, I'm a basketball player.
That's right. I wrote about it early on.
Yeah, I admired the player, but
after about 7 months, I gave up. I
want to move on to action, romance, or something like that.  Or romance, or action,
or romance, what do you mean? What do you like?
Yeah, yeah, wow. Those
two choices are strange, right?
Both are bad. That's true. Well then, what
other instrument do you want to learn next? Which
instrument do you want to learn
?  I kind of admire Daikaku and stuff like that, right? Yeah, it
looks like they're playing monkeys. Yeah, I want to be like that. I really like it, but it's really good. I
like the sound, so it's good.
Well, memorize
all of them. All of them. All of them.
Of all the bands, the one most likely to win the Oscar is
Noa
22, ah, 22, ah, me.
[Music] It's kind
of strange.  The main character
has become pretty gold. What's that girl in that movie doing?
Yes, she's the least likely to eat her fingers in the band. Who made it
?  It's like I'm a
glutton, like I'm going to
eat anything, and if I
pass, I'll eat just like
that.Food.  By the way, who is the
most interesting person in the band?
Who is the most interesting person to ask a deep question? What do you think is
interesting? Each of them is interesting.
Wait a minute. I have
n't decided yet.  No, I think it's a little impossible for me. I ca
n't choose. I can't choose. I can't choose. I can't
choose. I can't choose.
No, I thought it was Satoru, but if I
go to normal, I'll become Satoru. In the world's eyes, I guess I can't
choose.  It's
a little bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a that It's so boring It's really boring at home Because it's really boring at home You only
talk to the cat
Who is the first person to die in a horror movie?  That
means there are 4 people in it, right? The
one that feels like an accessory. It's
usually me. Well, it doesn't feel like that, but it's the one that
stays at the end. That's right. There are
three or so interesting ones. It's like this
at the end.  So, if there is a situation where there are about three people and
one of them has to die, you can't move on to the next one, and
when that happens,
I wonder who's going to die.
Who is the best dancer among the candidate bands? Could you please show me a little bit of dancing? Yes,
this will work. So that's it. There were
a lot of strange questions.
However, I hope you get to know us even just a little bit.It
was Kingnu
[Music]
T